so there's a picture of you along with
the rest of the intellectual dark web
in this big new york times by barry
weiss i know were you staying in a bush
or something like for some reason
everybody was in foliage
taking taking these pictures so what do
you make of the whole intellectual dark
web contingent
and there's been this now huge backlash
by a lot of folks particularly on the
left saying
what's up with this intellectual dark
web it's just a bunch of unacceptable
deplorable people talking with each
other
and they don't have anything to say what
do you make of the whole phenomenon well
the name
is all eric right eric weinstein yeah
yeah eric eric is crazy and uh he
loves like all the cloak and dagger and
all the
all the hidden the just the name of it
intellectual dark web it's like he
concocted that soros
yeah eric is he's brilliant i love him
oh yeah and i love
his i love his first person i have ever
met because and i can't understand half
of what he's saying
yeah he's he's he's a very intense guy
but he
loves all this stuff he gets a kick out
of it and i think
there's a certain amount of silliness in
calling it the intellectual dark web
when you and i are essentially in some
sort of a
super group what are we in we're super
friendly exactly
yeah and what i felt was fascinating was
that a lot of people were trying to
label us as like deplorable
conservatives
and like when they were saying this is a
group of renegade conservatives so
i'm pretty liberal like pretty liberal
across the board
if you you want to talk to me about gay
marriage you want to talk to me about
gay rights women's rights
drugs you go drugs you go down the line
universal health care universal basic
income i mean i'm pretty liberal
like it's it's but it doesn't fit the
narrative and i look like a trump
supporter
right so like it's this is a white
buffer yeah
yeah i'm a white bald guy it works out
too much there's
there's a lot of you know there's a
there's a lot of
need to label someone into an easily
dismissable
category and that that category is
conservative like
ruthless nasty mean uh
non and a person is not kind and not
not you're not a a person who's caring
about other people
you're a conservative you're a mean
bully mean mean
mad white man as was his name uh that
said that to jordan peterson and the
monk debates
michael dyson i think isn't it michael
eric dyson yeah yes that's what i love
tyson yeah he called jordan peterson a
mean mad white man
a mad me one of those yeah but it's uh
there's there's this
need to catch brian hersey ali and half
the people who are
who are members of the members of the
club
exactly dave rubin who's gay right like
it's hilarious
it's it's this really like bizarrely
diverse group and really ideologically
diverse too because
it's a bunch of people i mean like brett
weinstein who's a member of the of our
secret
our secret group he's he's a socialist
he backed bernie sanders in the last
election
yeah uh and so so what do you think
generated i wasn't just
the political correctness the insanity
the hard left it threw everybody out
dishonesty
it's dishonesty it's the same thing that
led to
what happened with brett weinstein at uh
evergreen when they had this day
of absence where they wanted all white
people to stay home
he's like hey this is racist like you're
you're you're
you're you're absolutely targeting
people
based on their race and saying you're
not welcome here this is a day
instead of it being a day of absence
where people of color
stayed home voluntarily and weren't
chastised if they didn't
instead of that it was no white people
have to go away
and if you don't you're a racist and
this is what happened with brett and
it's a terrifying story and when i
interviewed him on my podcast it was
before
he had left evergreen he was still
employed there and he was talking to me
about
mobs that were wandering the parking lot
with baseball bats and they were looking
for him
and it was terrifying he had to get he
had to take his family out of the state
and who is this is this are these nazis
are these the kkk are these these
right-wing thugs no
they're extreme progressives with pink
hair
who who are you know non-binary sexually
like
it's very bizarre and there's a
lack of reality that you you have to
adhere to this narrative and if you're
not adhering to this narrative
then you are some horrific person
who is a product of the past and you're
a part of the patriarchy and
it's not an honest discussion these
if you if you see all the people that
are involved
in this you know air quotes intellectual
dark web the one thing they have in
common
all of them are going what in the is
everybody talking about like what is
this
what's happening here like why why are
we pretending that men and women aren't
different things
why why are we pretending that to tell
people that you have to stay home
because you're white it's
racist that is absolutely racist by
definition
that's what racism is you're
discriminating against someone based on
the race not based on their character
or their job position or anything else
you're just just white people
totally agree i mean i think that the
concepts that seem to have united this
group of people who again are all over
the place on everything from religion to
free will to politics
is one we all like data and we're
interested in data so if you present us
with data we're all happy to take a look
at it
and maybe change our opinions based on
the new data that you're presenting yes
that's very important and and two that
we're willing to have conversations
about those data without regard for the
political
niceties yes and then and three that
we're all i think big into the idea of
treating people as individuals that if
you're going to treat me as a member of
a group i'm really not interested in
talking to you
and i'm not interested in being labeled
as a member of a group either yeah so
we're a group of people who don't like
groups basically which is kind of
hilarious
but that is exactly what it is a group
of people who don't like groups
but we're also very friendly and kind
and i'm sure you and i disagree on a
bunch of things but we agree on a lot of
things as well
but what i like about you is you're a
very reasonable intelligent person
that is you you're a very polite person
the way you talk to people is very
polite
i think that's something that's part of
my reputation me being polite
you are a polite person you're a very
kind polite person
and i think that this there's something
missing with this
this ideo idea war that people are
engaged in
where they want to demonize people that
disagree with them instead of just
sitting down and talking with them and
saying well why do you think this
okay let me let me try to look at it
from your perspective this is why i
disagree
and have a polite exchange of ideas
instead everyone's fighting for their
life as if you know
whether or not trans people can use the
girls room is going to change the course
of history it's strange
it's strange like these battlegrounds
the lines that people are drawing in the
sand and
and if you're on the other side you're
the enemy and you need to be shut down
and stopped it's
it's very it's a very weird time the
level of anger is really really
troubling
and and that's something that i do feel
like is kind of new so i've spoken on
college campuses for a long time because
i'm 34 now but i started doing this
stuff when i was 17 or 18 years old and
i was speaking on college campuses when
i was 20
and i never had to bring security with
me to any of these college campuses
ever until the last three years the last
three years i now have to have at least
a two-man security team at every college
campus
and usually it's more than that based on
what the police are telling us about
reports in advance now
half the time nothing materializes but a
few times things have materialized and
it's been
trouble and and that that sometimes
happens where do you think this level of
anger is coming from because it appears
to me that that's what's new like these
political divides have always existed
these political divides between right
and left
or political divides between people who
are more interested in collective
solutions versus individual solutions
why do you think people are so pissed
all the time and they're just
you can feel it in the air like the the
eagerness to stomp on somebody's face
is really strong that's why when the
roseanne thing happens it can't just be
like what you're saying
where okay she's a mentally ill person
maybe you have to take the show off the
air maybe that's the proper response
but she might actually have a problem
here she
she certainly does um what i think it's
coming from is toxic tribalism
that's what i think i think people uh
they're on a team
they want their team to win and they
want their team to win by any means
necessary and they're
they feel disenfranchised because we
have a president
you know donald trump i mean he is who
he is and
he stands for a lot of things that they
find abhorrent
and you you have a lot of people now
that are calling themselves antifa
and they're they're by literally by
their own actions
acting in a fascist manner and they're
calling themselves anti-fascists
and they're putting bandanas in their
face they're hitting people with bike
locks and
they're engaged in violence and the the
left
is using violence as a means to solve
these differences that we have and ideas
and opinions they're shutting people
down like christina hoff summers
just yelling out at her a woman who's
her whole life
has been a feminist her whole life and
she calls herself a factual feminist
because she wants women who are
empowered and who are intelligent to be
held accountable for their
the actual facts behind what they're
saying and
you know to to discuss this to empower
people with reality
and by doing that she's become an enemy
i mean it's very strange to watch her
get shouted down by
other feminists that think that she's
the wrong kind of feminist
it's it's really bizarre but
the anger and the vitriol and the the
the violence that's attached to it is
something that's completely new
and was always associated with
right-wing thuggish mobs
it was always associated with hate
groups like the kkk
or or some something along those lines
you know
neo-nazis but you're seeing this level
of violence
from from the left now these weird
like university professors and these
dorky people that are saying burn this
down and
and people are cheering the streets and
white people with a problem and
and there's so many people that are
tenured professors that are getting away
with saying like ridiculous crazy
and calling out for violence and it's
completely irresponsible
and it's it's it's foolish i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the ben shapiro
show sunday special if you did
go ahead and hit the subscribe button so
you stay up to date on all of our future
content